ich habe mich beschäftigt wenn ich in
diesen tagen die diskussion beobachte
was wir in den zwei jahren corona
überhaupt gelernt haben ich dachte wir
hätten mal gelernt dass wir nicht mehr
auf die inzidenz werte achten denn es
sind sehr viele deutsche trotz aller
debatten geimpft das sind du hast die
zahl gerade schon genannt das
robert-koch-institut sagt nur 67 hat
aber selbst eingeräumt dass sind
mindestens 80 dann kommen noch die
genesenen dazu werden ungefähr 85
prozent sein die geimpft sind damit ist
die reine orientierung an den incidents
werten nicht mehr maßgeblich uns
vorsichtig zu formulieren diese
incidents werte werden aber heute wieder
jeden tag als spitzen und alarmmeldungen
durch die medien gepusht jeden tag und
die leute geraten in aufregung dadurch
dabei ist ein ganz anderer wert
maßgeblich die frage ist wer kommt in
die kliniken wie viele kranke kommen mit
corona die kliniken da gibt es die
hospitalisierung 's rate die kann man
auch problemlos erfahren und erfahren
die hospitalisierung rate die sagt wie
viele kranke bezogen auf 100.000 bürger
kommen sind in den letzten 7 tagen in
kliniken gekommen das sind im moment in
deutschland
3,93 diese zahl ist seit ende oktober
deutlich gefallen da waren es 5,7 und 70
also nicht gestiegen sondern gefallen
und wenn man es vergleicht mit der
zweiten und dritten welle in der zweiten
welle im dezember 2020 waren es 15 statt
3,93 in der zweiten welle jetzt im
vergangenen april waren es knapp zählt
das ist immer noch ein riesenunterschied
und damals sind die kliniken auch nicht
zusammengebrochen wir erleben im moment
einen propagandafeldzug mit angst mache
gegen die nicht geimpften indem man sagt
ihr seid schuld daran wenn die kliniken
volllaufen und normale leute nicht
operiert werden können weil die weil die
notfall wetten aufgebraucht sind aber es
gibt in deutschland ungefähr 22.000
notfall betten übrigens 4000 weniger
ganzen vergangenen jahr woran die
politik und die klinikkonzerne nichts
geändert haben und gemessen an den
22.000 betten sind nur
2600 ungefähr von corona betroffen in
thüringen ist der spitzenwert erreicht
da sind von den notfall betten etwas
über 21
21 2 durch corona belegt ein fünftel
vier fünftel eben nicht und was hören
wir jeden tag das geht alles in ganz
schrecklichen weg die kliniken laufen
voll märchen es sind märchen und es
waren früher auch märchen man muss das
ernst nehmen wenn die zahlen sich
wirklich dieser grenze dann tun sie aber
nicht und da sage ich mir also im moment
kann ich nichts anderes sagen als
hysterie frisst hirn und ich habe
langsam den eindruck dass maßgebliche
figuren der korona politik ein interesse
tragen haben der neuen regierung ein
scherbenhaufen hin zu hinterlassen
nämlich ein in hysterie versetzt ist
volk das problem ist doch dass wir
inzwischen einen erheblichen
glaubwürdigkeitsverlust erleben sowohl
in die institutionen in die politik in
das sprachrohr der gesundheitswirtschaft
jeden tag im prallen die vielen
meinungen auf uns ein und keiner glaubte
suazo und wenn man so eine auffassung
wie sie vertritt dann ist man sowieso
gleich einen verschwörungstheoretiker
und ein querdenker und was weiß ich ich
habe regelmäßig bei mir zu hause in
meinem büro leute die sagen wir können
unsere meinung nicht mehr frei sagen und
ich finde wir müssen als politik
glaubhaft machen dass das was wir tun
das woran wir arbeiten immer das ziel
verfolgt die freiheit zu wahren in
diesem land und vor allem auch getreu
der wahrheit verfährt so und das im
austausch mit allen wissenschaftlern in
diesem land nicht nur mit rein sondern
mit allen es gibt viele meinungen es
gibt viele auffassungen die wahrheit ich
meistens in der mitte ja und das ist uns
glaube ich das ist uns glaube ich
verloren gegangen deswegen gehen die
leute demonstrieren dass wir glauben sie
uns nicht mehr deswegen schließen sie
sich tatsächlich auch
verschwörungstheorien auch nicht gerecht
die zahlen die ich eben genannt haben
sind alles offizielle zahlen des robert
koch- institut alle wie kann ich ja
nicht erfinden die habe ich auch nicht
aus obskuren quellen geschöpft sondern
es sind alles offizielle zahlen da muss
man auch mal ein bisschen denn denn in
den medien so flach über dem kopf
schlagen ja die sonne das denken
anfangen ich meine dieses blatt hier und
auch diese sendung hier hat immer den
eigenen kurs verfolgt immer muss ich
sagen und hat richtig gelegen damit aber
aber ist es aber sich anzuhören dass
wieder die kliniken volllaufen und das
normale leute damit ruft man ja druck
auf die ungeimpften zu erzeugen das
normale leute nicht mehr am herz
operiert werden können oder keine
schlaganfall operationen mehr kriegen
also dann sterben weil ungeimpfte in
großen mengen in die kliniken drängen
das ist eben nicht so wenig sehen wir
nicht hans ulrich jörges hier die
ouvertüre zu dem großen spiel opposition
also union ja gegen die ampel wenn wir
mal schauen wer jetzt auch am lautesten
ruft dann ist das natürlich der
bayerische ministerpräsident dann ist
das der ministerpräsident aus sachsen
einmal csu einmal cdu dann will ein
laden der ministerpräsident aus dem
nordrhein- westfalen ebenfalls cdu zu
einem corona gipfel also wir sehen
natürlich auch bei denen natürlich sind
die inzidenz in bayern und sachsen sehr
sehr hoch die müssten die wir in
deutschland haben aber wir sehen
natürlich hier das erste den ersten
aufgalopp zu dem was jetzt kommen wird
vier jahre lang die front ist klar auf
der einen seite die ampel parteien und
auf der anderen seite die union und da
bringt sich unter anderem markus söder
jetzt kräftig in stellung berichtet
michael kretschmer aus sachsen natürlich
auch der will auch noch was werden in
ihrer parteien wir sehen einen jungen
ministerpräsidenten henrik wüst der hat
eine landtagswahl zu bestreiten nächstes
jahr im mai muss sich natürlich auch
bekannt machen und ich will das jetzt
nur auf diese parteipolitische rolle
abwälzen aber das ist glaube ich viel
training wo man sagen kann hier geht
jetzt der schwarze block gegen den rot
gelben moment ohne frage wir sind in der
opposition und da geht es natürlich auch
die abteilung attacke zu bedienen ohne
frage aber bei corona geht es doch wie
bei keinem anderen thema darum in der
sache die richtige lösung zu finden ja
und nicht parteipolitik zu machen es
geht um die leute frieren noch ist die
union geschäftsführend in diesem langen
abend ja noch nicht die opposition sie
haben ja eigentlich ein corona politik
zu verantworten muss man sagen dass
vielen menschen die freiheit und die
meinung man sollte also ich hab ich habe
dass ich habe das auch immer kritisiert
und wir reden jetzt über 2g wir reden
über den ausschluss von unschuldigen von
gesunden menschen aus dem öffentlichen
leben und ich sage ihnen ganz ehrlich
ich mache mir über die verfasstheit
unseres landes mit der frage große
sorgen wie erleben dass unternehmer das
geschäftsführer ihre beschäftigten in
andere büros unterbringen andere
kantinen unterbringen hallo was soll das
wenn so viele geimpft sind dann gehen
sie doch davon aus was sie geschützt
sind zumindest fürs erste ja also was
soll diese art von leben von politik von
entscheidung und alle machen mit larissa
ich kann ja gerade zum beispiel eine
weihnachtsfeier für mein team gar nicht
anständig planen ja ich würde gerne das
nach einer 3g regel machen weil ich der
meinung bin also als arbeitgeber darf
sicher ohnehin den impfstatus nicht
abfragen ist eine ganz schwierige
diskussionen die wir auch in meinem
verlag
diskutieren dh wenn ich eine zweig regel
dann bin ich eine lokalität
wehle und in hamburg wo meine redaktion
sind sind wichtig überschlags jetzt
wahrscheinlich 90 prozent der
gastronomie neu inszeniert nach zweig
das heißt es ist schwer eine location zu
finden ich darf den status natürlich
nicht abfragen ab als arbeitgeber das
heißt ich suche eine location aus und
sehe dann von den leuten die nicht
erscheinen wahrscheinlich um geld schon
gar keinen bock kein bock mit ihrer
chefin zu feiern genau
das
ist aber damit dass genau sich selber
höher
auf jeden fall ich finde das eine
schwierige diskussion auch vor allem in
so eine situation gebracht zu werden
darf ich darf nicht abfragen macht er
indirekt aber dennoch und was auch
bedeutet sie haben und sie haben völlig
recht mein eindruck ist ohnehin das im
moment alles zertrümmert wird was wir
mal an gewissheiten hatten wie kann man
denn gleichzeitig zweig verlangen
länderweise und die tests finanzieren
vom staat aus der staatskasse entweder
oder was willst du denn mit den test
anfangen wenn man nicht im lokal oder zu
einem kanada irgendwo rein der stopp und
das andere ist jetzt wird ja ständig
über die booster impfungen geredet das
hat den nebeneffekt dass zu einem
zeitpunkt wo leute unter druck gesetzt
werden sich zum ersten mal impfen zu
lassen diese ersten impfungen quasi
entwertet werden sind die nix mehr wert
muss man unbedingt eine dritte haben
sind die schon verbraucht wie lange
halten die denn das sind alles
unbeantwortete fragen die von der
politik sondern raum geschoben werden
was sollen leute damit anfangen sie
kriegen angst ich finde es wunderbar wie
sie hier argumentieren muss ich sagen
ich habe noch kein cdu politiker gesehen
der so mit menschenverstand und offen
die fragen diskutierten das stimmt ist
schon gelohnt das ist doch ein ritt auf
der rasierklinge aber die abgeordnete
sind unserem gewissen verpflichtet und
dann kommt erst mal ganz lange nichts
und ich finde das ist gerade bei einer
frage wie corona wichtiger denn je